Hunter Biden who has spent the better
part of three decades peddling his
father's influence as one of the most
powerful politicians in America in order
to enrich himself and really I guess to
enrich his family the big guy too Hunter
has finally been charged after a federal
investigation into his countless
Financial sexual pharmaceutical and
Firearm related crimes and what was
Hunter charged with
two misdemeanor tax offenses and a gun
violation
that's all now even the minor charges
that Hunter ultimately faced could have
landed him in prison for a dozen years
but since Hunter pled guilty as part of
a deal with prosecutors he now faces uh
uh probation
probation for the tax charges and a
diversion program for the Firearms
charge a diversion program that he
doesn't even appear to be legally
eligible for that means that that latter
or gun charge will likely be wiped from
his record no prison no real punishment
no nothing
the plea deal doesn't even mention the
countless sex and Drug crimes that
Hunter committed on camera crimes that
he recorded himself doing
but forget about the sex and the drug
stuff for just a second the whole point
of the inquiry
was Hunter's massive influence peddling
operation in which he traded his
father's power as vice president for
massive bribe's worth reportedly at a
bare minimum 10 million dollars with
this plea deal the actual crime of
public interest is effectively swept
under the rug which means that this
prosecution is not a prosecution at all
it's a cleanup operation by Joe Biden's
political enforcers masquerading as law
enforcement law enforcement that now
needs to get back to its Chief task of
imprisoning the leader of the opposition
I'm Michael Knowles as the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by some of my favorite
people good ranchers get great meat at a
secure price and 30 off your order with
my code Knowles kwles go to
goodranchors.com use code Knowles today
this is a great day I'm very very
excited because
an ex-pentagon official
who worked specifically on UFOs seemed
to kind of run that UFO program for a
little bit
he would appear
to confirm my view
on ET over the view of my beloved friend
and colleague Matt Walsh so we'll get to
that as that for a tease first though
I'll tell you I'm starting to think
starting to think we might have a
corrupt political order
now speaking of rigging presidential
politics I just found out that YouTube
has censored
my friend and colleague Jordan Peterson
because Jordan Peterson did an episode
of his show with RFK Jr RFK Jr who is
somewhat significantly challenging Joe
Biden for the Democrat presidential
nomination when when RFK Jr announced
that he was going to run people kind of
laughed they thought of him as a fringe
kooky figure but he's polling somewhere
around 20 in the Democrat Party and then
all of a sudden RFK Jr's interview goes
away
why is that I was talking to my producer
Mr Davies Mr Davies came in he said
that's so weird I thought that you can
now question
vaccines on YouTube previously on
YouTube you couldn't but I thought now
they changed the rules and they said
that you can and I told him Mr Davies
that might be true
but you're not allowed to seriously
challenge Joe Biden on YouTube I don't
think that RFK Jr is being censored
because of anything he said about the
vaccines whether we're talking about
regular old vaccines or the coved
vaccines or I don't think he's the
reason he's being targeted
is because he poses a challenge to the
system to the liberal establishment
why was my channel on YouTube taken down
for one week
well it's because I
used pronoun I don't even know what I'm
allowed to say on YouTube anymore I used
pronouns that happened to be accurate
but they weren't politically correct and
so YouTube didn't like them I talked
about depressing social issue that is
contentious it's not contentious in the
reality of that issue everyone knows how
human nature works but it's contentious
in what the radical liberal Elites will
allow us to talk about what what versus
what the people actually believe and so
they took took me down for that but why
did they take me down I've been saying
that sort of thing for years as have
many other people well it's because this
is
pretty big Channel and it gets a fair
amount of reach and Not tooting my own
horn but it does influence the public
conversation to some degree and so
YouTube said okay we're gonna get him
just like we're gonna go get Matt Walsh
just like we're gonna go get Candace
Owens now like they're gonna get
Jordan Peterson
has nothing to do with the specific
rules which are always changing anyway
and in fact the reason that they're
always changing the rules is in part so
that they can wield power capriciously
to go after political enemies why are
they Prosecuting Trump for a less
egregious version of the crimes that
many of the most prominent recent
Democrats have committed themselves
including the sitting President Joe
Biden well because they don't like Trump
and Trump's leader of the opposition so
they're going to go after him I use this
phrase political order specifically here
I don't just say our government is
corrupt or Washington DC is corrupt I
say the political order because we are
governed at least as much by Google and
YouTube and the big Tech platforms as we
are by some elected officials in D.C in
fact we're governed I think in many ways
far more by the big Tech platforms we're
govern at least as much by the big Tech
platforms as we are by the
administrative state by the bureaucrats
by the media that shapes the public
conversation
and all the rest it's a whole system and
when you go after the system they're
going to get you and they're going to
get you through all the various means
they're going to deep platform you
they're going to debank you they're
going to ostracize you they're going to
get you fired from your job and maybe
they'll prosecute you as well they won't
prosecute you if you're Joe Biden's son
who ran a massive pet influence peddling
operation for over 10 years but they
will prosecute you if you're Donald
Trump and you kept a letter that Kim
Jong-un wrote to you when you were
president
now speaking of presidential families
speaking of Donald Trump
there is some good news out there for
many people in the Maga base there's
some good news out there for you as well
by the way if you want good food you got
to check out good ranchers right now go
to goodranchors.com use promo code
Knowles as our great nation's birthday
approaches we are coming together as
proud Americans and savoring the
delicious Taste of homegrown American
made meet our friends of good Ranchers
have the best Quality Meats you've ever
tasted they only sell meat that was
raised here in the USA from now until
Independence Day good ranchers will be
offering the best deals to give you
freedom from the meat aisle from Ribeyes
near strips all natural Burgers to the
most delicious chicken you could ever
want good ranchers has something for
everyone plus right now you will get 30
off with our code Knowles at
goodranchers.com this is the way to wow
your family the Fourth of July
I am very Discerning about my meat I eat
a lot of red meat and these guys they're
just the best in the business they've
got the best quality they've got by far
the best prices they're just great guys
with a great company It's All American
made so what are you waiting for
let the mouth-watering aroma of American
made me fill the air bringing Joy unity
and delectable flavors to your
celebrations goodranchers.com use code
Knolls get 30 bucks off any box promo
code notes goodranchers.com
goodranchers.com American Meat delivered
good news out there for people who
really like the Trump family and good
and actually good news for people who
don't really like the Trump family and
don't want them all that involved in a
trump Administration president Trump has
come out and said that his family
will have no role in the next
Administration
would you want Jared and Ivanka to serve
in a second Administration no I don't I
said that's enough for the family you
know why it's too painful for the family
my family's been through hell
I mean they've Eric my son is a fine boy
you know him very well he's a fine young
man
good student good everything comes in
we're doing beautifully then I decide to
run for president I mean I don't think
anybody in the world in history has ever
had more subpoena sent to him nobody has
been through what my family has been
through Ivanka had a really successful
line of clothing I mean making a fortune
when I did this he was really she closed
it up she sort of felt she had to but
she blows it up uh my other boys were
doing great and I said instead of let's
take advantage of being president I mean
some people would say that's stupid
because everyone else has done it Nancy
Pelosi is worth 125 million dollars I
read and she never got paid more than a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
year how does that happen how does that
happen yeah you want to go through this
all again because I want to make America
great again we had a great we had a
great we were respected all over the
world very simple I want to make America
great again
very simple and so that means the family
is not going to be involved this time
this might help Trump politically
because I think a lot of people even
Arden Trump supporters don't like how
involved his family was
I don't know all of Trump's family I've
met some of them the ones that I've met
and talked to I I like but I think
probably this is a net political benefit
for Trump and still there's a storm
cloud here to this Silver Lining or a
silver line hit the storm cloud or I
don't know I'm mixing a lot of metaphors
here
the downside is that this is an
admission that personnel has been a weak
point for Trump and it's the line that
Brett Bear hammered him in in that
interview that just took place on Fox
News and it's a point that a number of
Trump's opponents of hammered him it
which is hold on President Trump you
surround yourself with the best people
and yet you end up turning on your
secretary of state you end up turning on
your Chief of Staff you end up turning
on your press secretary and attorney on
this person to turn on that person so if
if you got the best people around you
why why do you later come to attack so
many of them
and it's a it's a good line I think the
honest answer to that line is well it's
hard to get people to work for me
because a lot of people want to suck up
to the political establishment they know
if they work for me it's going to be a
black mark on their resume for the rest
of their lives and so we've had to
choose from a different array of people
that's the most charitable view to the
Trump Administration the second answer
to this is that there are just competing
factions within the Trump Administration
and sometimes one faction is up
sometimes another faction is up in which
everyone falls out of favor they're
going to Bear the brunt of a lot of
issues but regardless it does look a
little bit like a weak point and yet I
don't think It ultimately really hurts
him and the reason I don't think It
ultimately really hurts him is the
reason that Trump has been so resistant
to so many attacks the reason they call
them the Teflon Don
after the first one first one was John
Gotti the second one is Donald Trump and
the reason for that is
the whole point of a trump candidacy is
to be a wrench in the system
that's why people voted for this guy so
the fact that he's not polished the fact
that sometimes often the people don't
work out the fact that things get gummed
up and messed up and the execution is
sometimes a little haphazard that is
ultimately I think just part and parcel
of the Trump Prospect
which is
hey this whole political order that
we've got here yeah it's kind of a
uniparty oligarchy sham and if you vote
for me I'll just gum it up for a little
bit I'll expose some of the corruption I
Will Show You by virtue of my presence
how how vindictive it can be because
they're going to come after me and
they're going to try to cook up bogus
evidence about me colluding with the
Russians and they're going to try to
investigate me ultimately they're going
to try to impeach me twice and they're
going to try to throw me in prison
ultimately because I had some documents
so
if if your candidacy is hey this
political order is messed up and I'm
going to break it then the fact that you
got eccentric people who often don't
work out that doesn't really matter I
traveled to a lot of college campuses
I'm speaking to some young people here
at the Young Americas Foundation tonight
in Southern California and I ask them
now whenever we have a little dinner or
meet and greet before after the event I
say hey I know it's tedious but I got to
get your thoughts
who are you picking in 2024
the vast majority of them will say look
I like Trump but I prefer somebody like
DeSantis so I'll probably support
somebody like DeSantis this year but I I
voted for Trump or would have voted for
Trump I just don't really think he can
win again but if Trump is the nominee
I'll still vote for him happily that is
the answer that I get North certainly
north of 80 percent of the time probably
north of 90 percent of the time
and that answer sounds like it's good
for DeSantis because these young people
prefer DeSantis in 2024 but I think it's
ultimately better for Trump and it's not
just young people by the way I was
speaking to some some friends of mine in
Nashville who are a little more on the
retired side you know they're a little
bit older a little more of a classic GOP
voter they gave the same answer that the
college kids do I don't know I don't
think Trump can win again I wish he
wouldn't run I just don't think he can
do it again and I said yeah yeah that's
all well and good but you could put a
bullet in Donald Trump's head he would
still run for president okay so that's
him dropping out him not running that's
not going to happen so knowing that
Trump's in the race what do you think
and they say well you know okay he'll
probably get the nomination and I'd be
happily vote for him in the general and
that is really good news if you're
Donald Trump because it means that you
got a 30 point Delta right now you got
30 points that you can fall that's how
high up he is on the number two guy in
the race and you'll still likely win the
nomination and then when you win the
nomination people are going to vote for
you
whereas there are probably
a fair number of people who vote for
Trump who might not vote for other
candidates because they're not typical
voters maybe 2016 was their first time
voting they are not traditional
Republicans they're not traditional
conservatives they're people who who
rightly recognize that the system is
deeply corrupt and they want to just
give a middle finger to that system and
not just to the people in Washington DC
but to the whole corrupt political order
with the media with the big tech
companies with the big corporations with
all of it so what does this mean for
Trump well you still got to face this
Federal indictment that he's got so this
the court case for the documents has
been set the court date is set for
August 14th that means that this court
case is going to be a major aspect of
the 2024 primaries some people thought
that it was going to be delayed for a
long time and they were going to drag it
out forever they seem to be trying to
get this thing done pretty quickly of
course it's the best show it's the most
entertaining thing that could happen
you're going to have court appearances
right before debates if the debates even
happen so I'm not making any predictions
you know you know I try not to predict
the future too much even though I can't
get my crystal ball at sometimes it's
fairly accurate the
Fair bit of this primary is going to be
dependent on external events beyond the
campaigns of trump or DeSantis or who at
Chris Christie or whoever it's going to
be a lot of it's going to depend on
things that we've never ever seen before
in American politics like a former
president being indicted and so
predictions are fairly useless at this
point
speaking of colorful Rich guys getting
indicted
Andrew Tate
the most Googled man in the world at one
point
has finally been charged in Romania
with rape human trafficking informing an
organized crime group to sexually
exploit women who is Andrew Tate Andrew
Tate is a self-help Guru social media
influencer guy he's very very talented
at going viral on the internet
I he has a lot of Defenders
especially among young people on the
right especially and you know he's not
like sitting at home reading his Edmund
Burke in a bow tie this is a guy who's
very Brash he makes comments that are
often very offensive some of them are
kind of bizarre like he defended
he said that he would rather
sleep with a trans like a man
who looks really good then a old really
old he said what was the I want to get
the line exactly right he said I would
rather sleep with a trans woman who
looks like Megan Fox than a
an actual woman who looks like Hulk
Hogan or something to that effect and so
he's just really good at going viral and
I've been charged with all these crimes
and a lot of people are are defending
him
and I think I am both much less and more
inclined to defend this guy than a lot
of people because a lot of androgate's
Defenders don't want to admit that
the guy is a pimp and Pimpin though it
ain't easy also ain't good this is one
of the videos that would seem to
incriminate Andrew tave in some of this
weird sex stuff
so the recruitment process is the same
as the PHD course
you message him on Instagram the PHD
course is my recruitment system I don't
mention webcam
until after I've had sex with a girl you
continue as normal no mention of webcam
you the girl after a girl you do
the PHD test if she passes the PHD test
and she wants to be with you
then you start mentioning things like
yeah but you know you're always busy
you're always at work you can come work
for me so you don't want girls in it for
money you want girl who's in it to be
with you so you meet a girl you take on
dates you or whatever she passes
the PHD test then you start saying
things like
oh yeah but you're always working I have
to do some traveling and you can't come
I want to bring you with me traveling is
a great one because the thing is about
this business is mobile if you can find
a good Airbnb with good internet you can
run it somewhere else so it's a good
little cabinet to throw in uh you're
always working why don't you work for me
so we spend more time together
so this is pretty dark stuff
he's he's here this is on
pickupartistools.com which is not in the
bookmarks of my web browser but you
might say well maybe he's just talking a
big game except he actually did have a
business where he was pimping at these
girls on online and what he's saying
here is so dark because he's saying
if you just offer the girl money it's a
consensual transaction so it's not rape
if you just offer the girl money she's
going to leave you once she makes the
money but if you seduce the girl and and
you deceive her into thinking that you
love her and you want to seriously date
her or marry her or something like that
then she's more likely to stick with you
and make you more money so that's what
you've got to do and that's really
really dark back in ancient Greece
seduction was treated as worse than rape
and we don't we don't think of that that
now we think of Seduction as totally
fine and kind of funny but seduction is
really really bad the argument among
those old ancient Greeks was that rape
violates the body obviously very very
bad but seduction violates also the soul
that that for that reason it it takes on
an even darker aspect and so this is all
really really
really bad stuff and I'm not inclined to
defend anybody who says this stuff and
much much less does this stuff as as
some kind of conservative hero or
something like that the very fact that
the guy was in Romania raises a lot of
questions because Romania is kind of a
dodgy place so you gotta ask like well
why would someone willingly go to
Romania okay now all of that said
all of that said
does everyone really think that this
indictment is a arrest and and later
indictment I guess is on the up and up
I don't think so they're clearly going
after this guy's money the charges
clearly seemed trumped up and then if
you want to go after this guy for
pimping women which I think is perfectly
fine in principle I gotta ask why aren't
you going after pharaohs and tune Farrah
santun is one of the founders and former
CEO of Mind geek which is the biggest
porn company in the world
why aren't you going after that that
guy's doing the same thing at a much
larger scale than Andrew Tate is why
aren't you going after Scott montgomer
he's the current guy running mind keep
why don't you go after what is her name
uh I'm Rob I'm rapaligan who's the CEO
of only fans all of these people are
pimping out women at a much larger scale
than Andrew Tate ever has why aren't
those guys getting arrested why aren't
those guys having their money stolen why
aren't those guys being held for months
without charges
you you don't need to defend Andrew Tate
or his view of the world and maybe he's
turned it around I think I read
somewhere that he converted to Islam
which is which is another conversation
that we could have I guess so you don't
need to really defend Andrew Tate to
point out
a fact that we have observed
increasingly in the United States which
is that the law is not being applied
fairly here it's not being applied
evenly it's just being applied to attack
people who in any way criticize the
regime you could be Bobby freaking
Kennedy you could be a Kennedy Democrat
royalty but if you and you can remain a
committed liberal but if you if you
question the regime on certain
instruments of its power and maybe you
go up against the guy who's at least
ostensibly running the regime they're
going to go after you they're going to
censor you you can pimp out women which
is now a fetid Hobby and Industry among
the liberal establishment but if you do
so and then use your platform to
criticize that same establishment oh
they're going to take all your money
they're going to rush you they're going
to throw you in prison why are we going
after these relatively low-level guys I
mean Android rotate is prominent enough
why are we going after guys who've
committed crimes in a relatively modest
way when we let the guys who commit
those very same crimes in a much more
egregious way
whether we're talking about classified
documents Hillary Clinton Joe Biden much
more egregious than whatever Trump did
Bill Clinton for that matter
why are we letting the people who commit
the real serious massive crimes off
the hook because it's a political
prosecution
now when you want to
do a little bit more for yourself like
buy a car you gotta go check out cars
saying right now go to carzang.com
Knowles buying a new car
it can be a stressful experience for
everyone
that's especially true if you're a
first-time buyer if you've got no credit
before you walk into that dealership
before you spend the entire day with the
crowds and the stress and the potential
to not even find the right car
you got to check out carzing carsing is
completely changing the way you buy a
car online by partnering with Credit
Agencies and lenders and over 25 000
dealers Nationwide carsing provides you
with everything you need before stepping
foot into a dealership once you find the
right car at your ideal budget all you
got to do is bring your saved deal
voucher with you to the dealership to
finalize your next ride is super simple
even if you're not in the market for a
new car you should check out carsing
anyway Carson's online window shopping
experience goes beyond mirror images you
can dive deep into each vehicle's specs
features and performance capabilities
zoom in on craftsmanship of the Interior
Marvel at The Cutting Edge technology
admire the meticulous attention to
detail that sets these cars apart from
the rest carzing helps make your
experience faster cheaper and less
stressful go to carson.com Knowles get
the best deals near you carzing.com
slash Knowles as you may know we have
been in an ongoing battle with some of
the biggest social media platforms out
there last month
Mr Walsh was demonetized on YouTube then
Candace and I both were suspended
entirely from the platform for seven
days not to mention the past two weeks
YouTube has struck three of Jordan
Peterson's videos from its platform most
of these so-called violations across all
channels have stemmed from our coverage
of the transgender debate I don't
consider it very much of a debate I'd
consider it an observation of plain
facts of human nature but they call it
controversial over there and so being
expected
to adhere to vague arbitrary and
constantly changing roles has become a
little bit frustrating these rules
contradict everything we stand for it's
become quite clear we cannot rely on
many third-party sites to support us
daily wire plus is the best platform for
you to find content that's free from Big
text vague guidelines so if you believe
in our work and in fighting for the
ability to debate some of the biggest
cultural issues facing us today and
frankly I'll go further than that
because you know I'm not some free
speech absolutist I wrote a whole book
about how we need far greater limits on
Free Speech but we must have
the right to speak the truth
what is so egregious to me about what
YouTube and the other big Tech platforms
are doing right now is not that they're
not letting us say whatever we want
without any limits because the answer to
bad speech is more speech and we need
all the free speech in the world that's
not it that's a liberal point of view
that's not a conservative point of view
but the conservative point of view is we
must have the right to tell the truth we
must not be forced to lie
some of the greatest tyranny one can
possibly imagine a true violation of our
Liberty and our soul to be forced or
greatly pressured to lie that's what
they're doing okay if you think that's
no bueno then now is the time to join us
what are you waiting for sign up today
you will get 25 off daily wire plus
dailywire.com subscribe join the fight
today
speaking of weird sex stuff I gotta get
to this is going around I gotta get to
it
Are you a gynosexual
are you
I'm not making any accusations I just
wonder if you're a gynosexual that's a
headline from Men's Health are you
gynosexual here's what it means
according to experts if you're attracted
to women or femininity it might be the
label for you and a lot of people are
sharing this around they say oh tihe
what a stupid new word hear those crazy
woke Libs go again just making up words
that's what they always do wow how silly
is this it is silly it is ridiculous but
it's clever too and I haven't seen
anyone else pick up on this there's a
reason that the libs make up all of
these words because they they help to
reshape and constrain the the vision
that people have of how reality works
and ultimately that is conducive to the
left's political project and the word
gynosexual here is really helpful to
them
because the libs currently have a
problem
and the problem is the way that they
talk about gender identity and sexual
orientation and all of these fairly
novel lib Concepts
remains subject dependent
such that
I'm a man
I like women I like one woman in
particular happens to be my wife
but I if we're talking about my natural
attractions I am attracted to women so
that makes me in our modern culture
straight
in other cultures you would say that
just makes you man in other cultures you
would say makes you normal but now we
say that makes you straight if you're a
man who's attracted to women
a woman who is attracted sexually to
other women is a lesbian
okay
what is a trans woman who is attracted
to other women
you could say that that person is a
lesbian but even the most Ardent
pro-trans Advocates kind of stumble on
that or they kind of giggle or they say
yeah that's not quite precise or yeah
okay you're right I don't know what do
we call that person so a word like
gynosexual solves a problem
a linguistic problem and a political
problem for the libs which is that it
divorces sexual orientation from the
subject
it's sidesteps that tricky question for
The pro-trans Advocates which is who are
we what are we what is human nature and
it just makes it all about the object of
Desire so now anybody a man a woman a
trans woman or any of these other new
identity Notions anybody who is
attracted to a woman is a gyno sexual
expect to see more of that
because we're all going to be giggling
about it until we're mandated to use
those terms and until among people who
are less conscious of these sorts of
things it
it starts to become culturally
normal
speaking of weird sex stuff
[Music]
now speaking of weird things finally we
get to this story
the biggest debate at the daily wire is
not over gender
it's not over the 2024 race and it's not
over immigration or the biggest debate
aliens
some people
like my colleague Matt Walsh say that
aliens are real E.T comes down abducts
people prowls around Little Green Men
and some people
are correct
such as yours truly who observes that ET
is fake it's not real
we are not alone in the universe but as
far as corporeal beings go with rational
Souls we are alone and that when people
see these unidentified flying objects
and when they think they encounter the
little green man they're most likely
just talking to demons and
it's amazing people make fun of me for
this
but the reason people make fun of me for
this point of view
is because they are moderns they're
modern secular Libs and aliens are
they're just demons for modern lib
people who can't imagine that there's
such a thing as metaphysical reality so
it's for people who are materialists who
who think that everything that's real
has to be flesh and blood which
obviously isn't true you know some of
the most important things in life are
not Material hopes dreams love
mathematics you know there are plenty of
things that are metaphysic the moral
order but
we have convinced ourselves in this
unsophisticated day and age that it's
all got to be physical and so
so even the celestial beings have to be
physical they can't be uh merely
spiritual now there's a fella by the
name of Luis Elizondo this is reported
by the New York Post although I got to
give a hat tip to Pope had here a great
sub stack writer and Tweeter who called
my attention to this Louis Louis
Elizondo is a Former Intelligence
officer with the Department of Defense
he claims he was the director of aatip
the pentagon's UFO program from 2010 to
2017. former Senate Majority Leader
Harry Reid has defended this guy and
said he actually was pretty prominent in
the government working on these things
here's what he had to say
I had one
I remember conversation very well
um this is a person I respected
tremendously very very senior person
he's told me he said Lou I want you to
stop stop doing this
I said okay sir I I certainly can't but
may ask why and he says well we already
know what it is now at that moment I I
honestly thought maybe it was our own
technology and I was running up against
some super uber secret sap and uh you
know they were telling me to stop and I
said okay sir so so it's ours
and he said no
that's not what I'm saying and he said
he asked me Point Blank have you read
your Bible lately
and I wasn't quite sure where he was
going with that I said well sir I I
think I know what it says where are you
going with this
and he said well then you would know
that these things are are demonic and we
should not be pursuing them yeah and uh
I I he was he wasn't kidding me but
that's exactly how how he felt so this
is a pentagon this is a Department of
Defense
official uh saying stop looking at UFOs
because they're demonic
correct
correct correct not only is this senior
apparently respectable Pentagon official
who is so admirable that one of the guys
who was running the UFO office there
really looked up to this guy but it's
correct in that that's obviously what
these things are now when you want to
fight off terrestrial things
like I don't know uh unlit cigars and
you know little Vermin and uh charcoal
you've got to go check out Grill Blazer
right now go to grillblazer.com grill
Blazers Grill duns are designed to do
everything from expertly searing your
Meats to lighting charcoal grills wood
stoves outdoor fireplaces and just about
anything you can think of that you would
need high power fire to use for your
problem this would also include cigars
as I have shown once or twice though
that is not recommended at home grow
Blazers offers two types of Grill guns
the grill gun basic is a high power
propane torch designed to Light charcoal
and wood grills and smokers burns up to
3 600 Degrees it's a 30 inch flame is
for anything you need the big bad torch
to do and I mean anything the SUV gun
has a shorter Barrel perfect for
professional Culinary Kitchen uses from
gently caramelizing roulette or other
sugars and fruits to rapidly searing
steaks outside on the grill you using
the grill gun may result in extreme
Grill Envy from your neighbors so user
caution is advised get your grill gun
from Grill Blazers today and let the
grilling Adventures begin visit
grillblazer.com and use promo code
Knowles for 15 off your order that is
grillblazer.com
promo code nulls for 15 off your order
my favorite comment yesterday is from
theoj615 who says we should let
Juneteenth and pride month fight it out
so true it's like the Iran Iraq war you
just hope they both lose
you heard it from the horse's mouth
the aliens are demonic now what's
interesting is this guy in this
interview from a couple of years ago
that not a lot of people seem to have
found uh this guy
seems to disagree with the respected
more senior Pentagon official who said
the stuff's demonic we shouldn't be
looking into it and this guy says no
we've got to look into it we've got to
go get all the data we've got to probe
this stuff we've got to find out what's
really going on
and my question is why why do we have to
do that
curiosity is not a virtue
why should we do that there is more in
heaven and earth a ratio than is dreamed
of in our philosophy and certainly the
desiccated modern philosophy that
ignores metaphysical things
but why why are we going to do this if
if there were which there is not a super
race of extremely intelligent ET that
are coming and they can mess with us and
they can probe us and they can cross the
Galaxy and then go faster than the speed
of lightning and do all this crazy stuff
their technology is so much more
advanced than ours is
then we're not going to beat them
you know that'd be like a squirrel
trying to beat an army of human beings I
mean we're just if we're that much
stupider than these things then we're
obviously not going to beat them
if
they're demons then we should want
nothing to do with them
C.S Lewis had a good bit on demons which
is he said the right attitude toward
demons is that you've you should know
that they exist because there is
spiritual reality we
we are Body and Soul we're hylomorphic
composite beings with a rational Soul
that's why we have an appetite we have
to eat food and drink water to sustain
ourselves man does not live by bread
alone and we can use our abstract reason
and moral judgment to think of things
like um Justice or art or culture or
Opera I don't know right we can we can
do both those things
certain beings are
are purely physical they don't have a
rational so like a rock
even the animals they don't they don't
have abstract reason we don't put them
on trial we don't put a dog on trial
when he bites you okay that's why and
then on the other side of things there
are
beings that are purely physical
I ideas are physical and angels and
demons are physical too and everyone has
known this for all of history until
modern Western liberal secular people
and like a hundred years ago so
if they are demons then C.S Lewis points
out the right attitude is know that they
exist be on guard you know they're
trying to
prey on Souls
tear you down to Hell and give you a bad
eternity and so we should know that but
we shouldn't be too curious about them
so it's kind of like bugs I don't know
you've got bugs in your house
you've got to be aware of that and take
care of the problem and like keep them
from coming in and kill the ones that
are there
but you don't want to spend a lot of
time with them you know you don't want
to spend your whole day thinking about
the bugs being around the bugs you just
want to get rid of them okay and that's
how I feel about
aliens who are really demons as the
Pentagon even admits okay speaking of
aliens
another kind of alien that we're trying
to keep out we've got a lot of people
crossing that border illegally and
there's a new candidate in the
presidential race this would be Francis
Suarez who is the mayor of Miami and
he's running I think to go after Ron
DeSantis and because everyone else is
throwing their hat in the race
Francis Suare as I said he doesn't seem
like the most Conservative candidate he
wore a big rainbow flag sash he seems
like kind of a lib and now that would
appear to be confirmed he was doing an
interview on Fox and was asked about his
thoughts on building a border wall and
here is his non-answer would you build a
wall
and if you do stop illegal immigration
would you allow the ones already here to
work the border is an enormous issue uh
we have 80 to 90 000 Americans dying
every single year from fentanyl that's
coming through our border that's being
pumped into our country from China
that's the equivalent of a 747 crashing
every single day and we're not treating
it as the crisis that it is we have six
to seven million illegal people that
have arrived in our country since uh
President Biden became the president
through policies that are creating chaos
at the border by the way that's a that's
a that's an issue that even Democrat
Mayors well are complaining will you
build a wall and put the ones who are
here already put into work will you do
those two things I will dedicate
whatever the resources that are
necessary also discussing it with the
law enforcement partners that are on the
ground to make sure that our border is
secure whatever that is I will do it
do whatever it is but I just don't make
me say I want to build a wall I don't
want to unless listen I'll do whatever
we're going to be serious about this
okay that's not a serious candidate good
on uh Varney there for going after as
far as I'm trying to get him on the
record will you build a wall or not
he doesn't want to say
and he's not going to be the president
obviously
as the GOP becomes less libertarian
and more socially conservative
you can expect
a stronger push to restrict immigration
all immigration illegal immigration
obviously but legal immigration too
that is happening I happen to think
that's a very good thing because I am a
little bit more of a traditional
conservative I'm not someone who thinks
that
individuals maximizing their autonomy is
is the greatest things that's life
spread so I'm really pleased to see that
but even if you are much more of the
libertarian bent and you don't want the
government at the local or federal level
involved in all that much and I don't
know you read John Locke and on Rand
every day
that is happening it's reflected in our
public opinion polls it's reflected in
chain in in now conservatizing views on
sexuality uh and bigger government views
on the right bigger government you know
a more robust government I guess you
would say a more active government or
government that can still be very
limited but robust and deficient and
effective within its proper spheres
which is the sort of thing actually the
founding fathers talked about
that is on the rise in education on
immigration
foreign policy a greater uh a greater
role for the American people in crafting
foreign policy
that's happening now I think that is
a really wonderful thing but don't
if you're running for president if
you're Francis Suarez you're you're
trying to ride a line between a past
that is gone right now what is defining
conservative politics not just in
America but around the world is a rise
in populism it's a rise in wielding some
power and it's a rise in this idea from
people who feel that their power has
gone away from them and in part they've
given their power away because they've
fallen into a utopian vision of a place
where none of us really wields the
government we all just live in a neutral
space and we're increasing realizing
this space isn't neutral there isn't one
system of justice here they're what
isn't the equal application of political
or economic power it's being used
wielded capriciously against us and so
the only hope we have is not to throw
our hands on the hair and say oh gosh I
this is terrible imagine if we were
doing that imagine if the roles were
reversed the only way to stop that is to
wield the power
ourselves which is why the two guys who
are leading the GOP race right now by a
country mile are the two guys who are
most explicitly saying I will wield
power for you and the two guys who have
a record of doing it okay
the member block is upon us today is
woke Wednesday we have some woke tick
tocks I'm told
I'm told we have the iPad
young Jacob do we have the iPad he's
just sitting over there keeping that
iPad all to himself
I'm looking at it desirously here you
can see young Jacob's hand creeping into
the frame
thank you sir
member block begins now daily wear.com
Knowles you just couldn't also check out
for two months free on all annual plans
see you there
[Music]
oh